[Music]
ladies and gentlemen my friend patton
oswald
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
thank you
it can be scary sometimes that was a
that was uh
i know that you meant that as a fan
but it had the tone of a threat
it literally had the you know what it
sounded like like at the end of the
action movie when the guy's trying to
get the bad guy to turn around like
patton
[Laughter]
you know
that's perfect yeah well the whole thing
i mean even a a rowdy crowd a good crowd
can feel like a threat have you ever had
an audience that was too hot
cause people love you you're you're i i
have had audiences i'm sure you've had
this too where they it's not there too
they're enjoying you incorrectly
where you're due like you'll do a joke
and like that yes that's right
okay and then they're just sort of
yelling and screaming how much they love
you i always said it's almost like i
have a
corn on the cob stand and i sell fresh
corn on the cob and i'm so proud of it
and every day a guy comes to my corner
of the cop stand and goes i love this
corn on the cob and just shoves it in
his ass
and i have to go
uh
that that's kind of not why i'm selling
it but thank you you know i can see
where he's coming from yeah i know
exactly like you can't he doesn't hate
you no but he's enjoying you incorrectly
right and that's a huge problem if
that's not what you wanted why'd you
butter up
it's a filthy shower well no but it is
it is a like uh a pray tell what do you
do with corn on the cob right right
right like
oh god we have a whole
paragraph to go through right now
[Music]